let's take a look at the Timeline as
laid out by the police CCTV footage
showed an electric bike approaching a
police van in Frank Road the bike then
turned around a minute later the bike is
followed by the police van without its
Sirens or lights turned on well the
police have narrowed the time of the
crash to 25 seconds at the same time the
police said the van was on Grand Avenue
four minutes later the police van
received information about the crash and
then made its way to the scene Dan
Whitehead has this report
48 Hours on from their deaths
significant questions remain unanswered
in this latest CCTV footage obtained by
Sky News Harvey Evans and kyrese
Sullivan are seen being pursued by a
police van
closer to the crash site the boys are
see riding all the way up Stanwell road
while the police van turns left towards
Grand Avenue it may have been around 14
seconds later that the fatal crash
occurred the pictures of forced South
Wales police to reveal a detailed
timeline
I am aware of concerns in the local
community regarding the timeline of
events which culminated in the Fatal
Collision it didn't go as any of us
would have wanted on the night of the
incident it is a tragic outcome 180
hours of body worn footage from officers
and hundreds of hours of CCTV is being
analyzed
South Wales police is clearly Under
Pressure to provide answers in what it
describes as a complex investigation the
exact nature of the police involvement
with these two young boys in the moments
before their death remains unclear it
will be a key part of a new police
Watchdog investigation
the independent office for police
conduct says it understands the public
concern and says it will fully and
independently investigate for locals
what unfolded here is still difficult to
process I was walking up the street
towards my little corner shop as I got
to the apartment Street I seen two boys
come around on an e-bike and seconds
after a police van coming around the
corner with no Sirens no lights
no nothing to even warn the public they
will come around the corner
family and friends of the victims laid
flowers at the scene today Harvey and
Kyrie's family paid their tributes our
hearts are truly broken by the sudden
death of Harvey we ask for peace within
the community and request that people
leave the investigation to the police so
we can get the answers we so desperately
need to lay Harvey to rest kairis's
family adding that he was a loving
caring handsome young man they were
loved by not only their families but by
their Community as well
police and the community both Keen to
not see a repeat of violence that
erupted close to the crash on Monday
night
Focus will turn to a vigil planned on
Friday to remember two young boys who
lost their lives
damn waited Sky News at South Wales
police HQ in Bridgend